i just have been scanned
probably an entirely different type
though councillor abbott welcome along
absolutely thank you
uh just a reminder lynn um that you'll
need to have your video on during the
meeting
so councillors um just before we kick
off a reminder of the updated protocols
that we've had in the email from mr
morris
around um
spacing obviously that's meant uh
an adjustment to the layout and we've
got the les nessman ruled lines in
between you and your neighbor
um
it also sadly reduces the number of
people we can have in the public gallery
fortunately enough for our public forum
speakers today
as chair i get to have my mask off for
the majority of the meeting
but
if you are masked on and by all means
please remove them
if you're speaking to the meeting but
make sure you put them back on and it is
kind of like being on an new zealand
flight if you've got to have a drink
obviously don't suck it through the mask
or you could
filter out the tea leaves
uh before we kick off lynn there is a
late item um that we'll be receiving uh
and
it might be that we're able to have that
emailed through to you but it's only
just been brought to us as a hard copy
now okay
but um it's a relatively short one and
staff will go through it at the time
you're comfortable with that lindsey
absolutely wonderful thank you
council of staff members of the public
my apologies for the delay uh thank you
for your attendance i'll declare the
meeting open
obviously we have uh councillor abbott
on zoom
i have apologies from councillor clark
councillor pottinger mrs coote and
lindsay mckenzie would somebody like to
move that those received
as cook and
this is
councillor sofa sorry
um put that all in favor
against
carrie two items in public forum are
both around vaccination passports uh
first up anna uh welcome along if you'd
like to
end sorry anne
my apologies
thank you for having me
um
hi see cura thank you for allowing me to
speak today
um i just want to share a few thoughts
um around vaccination passports i'm
obviously fully vaccinated myself and um
believe that vaccination is the best way
to control covet in the community
um however having been brought up in
invercargill and lived overseas in
london for a few years we came back to
invercargill my husband and myself to
bring up our family
and we probably used um council services
regularly on a weekly basis i.e when the
kids were little we took them to the
library for saturday morning reading and
craft activities
uh later on we would take them to the
pool when they were older for swimming
lessons and again museums on wet rainy
days to see henry and the observatory on
tuesday nights look at the stars so we
part of our weekly routine as a family
living in invercargill
was very much using those facilities and
that's why we came back here because
they were accessible and also cheap if
not free
um
however my concern is that i have a lot
of
friends family workmates who have
children
similar ages
that can no longer access these services
i've just spoken about
if we're looking at only three months
maybe six months
i would just say to them we'll suck it
up that's life
you know we've had to suffer because of
covet
but because i don't know if anyone in
this room can quantify say how long this
is going to go for
i would have liked to have seen i guess
a bit more thought put into it maybe a
longer term plan
to cater for this unique new group of
infocard rate payers
who um through their own personal
choices
which will affect their children um they
cannot access certain council services
anymore
um i just said we've got a bit of a look
at the long term plan thinking well you
know long term
be good to see what you guys have sort
of thought we are heading as a city
and i just read certain things which
probably annoyed me a wee bit was like
council will continue to consider the
needs of all its users
of its services
because our population is becoming more
diverse and i know we think more of
ethnic diversity but this is choice
diversity based on health again we've
got a different new diverse group of
people in our community that we have to
consider
um the other thing we i looked at is you
mentioned covert in your long-term plan
that was ratified in june
and you say that
you will measure
responses and on the long term impacts
on the well-being of communities that
require a long-term perspective in
response
and i don't see you doing that in this
instance a long-term response
to covet
i see more of a knee-jerk reaction to
what can be a scary situation and i
appreciate that that your concern is for
safety
but i would like to look
like to have seen you look at different
options for maybe certain days for the
pool to be um
just useful open to everybody i
appreciate that a lot of things can go
online but the pool can obviously not be
accessed online
um and the other thing is part of your
decision-making process again you
mentioned about active listening and
honestly with each other and respect and
i don't know if you've actually had a
chance
to listen to people's comments engage
how hey how many people using these
services in the community that aren't
vexed and also um their thoughts towards
it so that's just my observation as a
rate payer and also someone who values
um the free and accessible services that
invercargill has to offer to enhance
wellbeing of families in our community
which i've greatly appreciated myself
thank you very much thank you ann uh
council is open for questions
if not
sorry evelyn there you go
i'm i struggle with
the idea
that we are being blamed because
other people have made decisions that
affect children
the parents of the children are the
people who are making those decisions
yeah not us we're making decisions
there must be a question sorry there is
so how do you rationalize that okay we
have to rationalize this yeah i
rationalize the fact that adults make
decisions and they bear the consequences
um
and i respect that but you've got a
whole lot of under 12 year olds that can
no longer access these services because
of their parents decisions and that's
sad
i for instance i talked about we went
just to go to the observatory with our
son um take them to the i don't know if
you can do that anymore he's now a
software engineer in edinburgh leading a
team of software scientists that develop
satellites vanessa and that came from
accessing that service i don't know what
could come from visiting a swimming pool
but maybe something something of a
similar
was it gold medal exactly and it's the
children that i feel for and the worst
scenario would be those parents would
drop their kids at the pool unsupervised
you know and i i know that's been an
issue in the past and i would hate to
see that happen
um i agree that adults make choices but
the people i've talked about the friends
family you know they are saying
normal caring people who care about
their families
um and for whatever thought process they
have come to the conclusion it's not
right for them or their families to be
vaccinated i personally may not agree
with them but they are there and they're
in the community and we need to
accommodate the fact they do not think
the same as everybody else or the
majority of people in our community
councillor arnold
cool
my questions to you is just a bit of a
question is
is part of the frustration in your view
due to the fact that
since our last lockdown we've all been
pretty much carrying on as per normal
we've all been sitting close together
here no masks anybody could come into
here everybody could use all the
facilities
somebody's made a rolling
uh in wellington that has actually
changed everything yet nothing has
actually
actually changed do you think that's
part of the frustration um no part of
the reason i'm feeling that people don't
get vaccinated is possibly because
they've been you know it's it's they're
being told to do it
um you mean what so the question is why
people aren't being vaccinated
in your view is that part of the
frustration um no i mean i'm not
frustrated because i mean i i have
beliefs um that other people may not
agree with
and
you know and i know
people i talk who i've shared
before um have come to the conclusion
that it's not safe to be vaccinated for
them and i personally may not agree with
them but i respect them as an individual
you know i think part of the frustration
comes from the fact that up to say two a
week or so or two weeks ago they could
actually use everything access
everything
and nothing's actually changed and now
they can't
um
i think the frustration is they don't
probably feel like they've listened to i
think when there's a government mandate
people accept
that it's law that the government's
mandated it like with hospitality health
and education people know it's from the
government they can't fight it the
government's deemed
that this is to be safe and to be fair
the government has handled covert pretty
good up to now so most people accept
well if the government deems it to be
unsafe
okay we'll listen to them
but with the services
um obviously the library net the
government hasn't mandated but left it's
a city council to
decide and i think that's the
frustration for me is that you have a
chance to look at it a bit wider and a
bit longer and a bit deeper and actually
canvas the community
for these suggestions
do people care if someone is in a
swimming pool with them who's not
vaccinated i would suspect the chlorine
will kill a lot of the germs i don't
know but has have you is anyone paused
to look at this um
again i don't know
i just
suspect it looks a bit like a reaction
to me
and i don't like knee-jerk reactions
if you have time to look at them
properly and
to be fair covert is not in our
community rampantly at the moment
therefore let's pause take a breath and
look at this situation the library sure
we can go online it's more the swimming
pool that i feel kids are going to miss
out on
and i wish there had been maybe an
alternative
a couple of days a week where anyone can
go to the swimming pool
and again i don't know the number of
people you're dealing with
um quantitatively
thank you
councillors any further questions
councillor lewis thank you very much
thank you anna
i think we all anguish over the
ups and downs of good things back can
you just get into your microphone there
councillor lewis
i think we all anguish over this this
issue greatly if there was an outbreak
down here and
we have no idea if there's likely to be
one tomorrow with the twelve thousand
extra itself people coming down from
auckland perhaps
um the possibilities i'm not going to go
ask you the question of that because no
one knows exactly but if there was an
outbreak
how would
people who want absolute freedom
to every facility feel if the hospital
got jammed up yeah because
i believe i don't know if you know do
you have to know what
what facilities we have got down there
how many respirators we have okay
yeah so we'll take a step back i think
when i when i say a long term plan is to
actually build it into your plan like at
the moment
we haven't got ramper covert you know
open it a couple of days as soon as
covert is obviously a certain level of
the community
shut it down to non-vaccinated people
but at least consider a plan not a
knee-jerk reaction of all or nothing
straight away
i accept that we don't that would be the
first measure logically to reduce and
eventually maybe shut total lockdown
but obviously there's a there's a a
journey to that not a total lock down
straight away to non-vaccinated people
but i part of you your plan could be yes
why there is not a lot of covert in the
community let's try it for two days a
week
um just look at it at the moment we do
not know how this is going to play out i
mean cases have gone down in auckland i
don't know why we don't know how many
are going to come down here we no one
knows anything and that's just that
we're dealing on a day-to-day
week-to-week basis so let's
you know create a plan that deals with
that
um and has contingencies in place to
cope with different scenarios happening
in the community thank you for your
submission it's not my place to debate
and i thank you no no thank you for
listening
thank you any further questions
if not thank you and for taking the time
to come in and speak to us tomorrow also
thank you for the tone of your
submission as well oh okay
thank you
good day bye
mr tribe welcome along
thank
so we'll just bring the clicker down oh
yeah cheers
i'll take mine off i'm looking like
darth vader
well kia ora koto um most of you know
who i am
so the purpose of me being here today
obviously everyone's aware i've got a
vaccine pass i managed to get in the
door doesn't mean i'm vaccinated but i
have a pass
but for your well-being i am double
vaccinated stab jabbed and kebab
now the reason i've come today
again is
i looked at the
the item coming on the agenda last week
and thought oh yeah
it's sitting there read the report and
thought yeah my gut's going to tell me
that this committee's going to go with
what's currently happening
right because you had three options
paul
some or none
and that was it
um
so i've got to use slideshow basically
to go through decision making
um it might be telling you to suck some
eggs
but i'll run through it because i don't
believe
that council has taken everything into
consideration that it should have
and part of that
is the principles of local government
so it says there's certain ways that you
must act
one is having regard to the views of all
of its communities
now whether we like it or not we have
a community in this city that's
unvaccinated
it's becoming its own community
do i agree with them no
i believe everyone should get vaccinated
but again personal choice
so when making decisions
you should have consideration of the
diversity of the community
and
trust me it's getting very diverse we
have far left we have far right
we have some rather you got to put up
feral
aspects on both sides of the uh fence
and to me it's actually quite concerning
it could become a mental health problem
and again you can look at the interests
of future as well as current communities
and the likely impact of any decision
on each aspect of well-being now i'll
touch on this because it was raised
at the meeting the other day
and
again
action on behalf of communities and
promote the social economic
environmental and cultural well-being of
communities not the community of
communities
and you must in the course of
decision-making seek to identify all
reasonably practicable options
and assess them in terms of their
advantages disadvantages
and community views
you must give consideration to the views
and preferences of persons likely to be
affected by or have an interest in the
matter
now i noticed within the document it
said that you're not going to consult
because the community are aware of it
but are you aware of those individuals
views in the community
as to the effects on them
if you don't talk to them you don't know
um but again you can make judgments
and that's based on the significance and
i know within
mr cameron's
report said it's very significant
in terms of
the effect on people
um
so again
that significance when you make
judgments you've got to look at those
principles
and consider a range of options
or the views and preferences of others
so
i'll just leave that one up there it's
probably a bit hard to read
put my glasses on that's clearer
but when the government were actually
looking at the covered response
the human rights commission
gave them
some information and that's
specific conditions briefing that they
gave the government
and it says
if a measure involving less interference
with people's rights could achieve the
state of the objective that ought to be
used
they also went one step further and said
the government must be able to
demonstrate that it's
fully consider the potential negative
impact on people's human rights and
balance that against the societal
interest
an important element of this is to
explain why the proposed scheme
does not include the alternative and
of a negative covert test
for those who cannot prove that they've
been vaccinated
i went one step further
and said in considering the introduction
of vaccine certificates in new areas it
will be important to hear directly from
people who will be excluded from those
spaces
that was the human rights commission's
advice to government
or special conditions to consider so
within that
the dia
put out
guidance for local government
now within that dia's guidance
it talks about public facilities
so this says yes my premise is a public
facility there are no specific vaccine
pass requirements so it says go to step
eight
so step eight
it says we refer local authorities to
guidance
from the public service workforce
guidance which i've got a copy of here
and it says local authorities can and
should seek their own legal advice
and it doesn't mean the advice of lgnz
so within the public service workforce
guidance
it says where a prohibition does not
apply
agencies can consider
requiring members of the public who are
accessing premises
where public services are provided to
have a vaccine pass
agency considerations need to include
these factors the need to ensure
accessibility the nature of the service
the agency's health and safety risk
assessment and vaccination policy i
never saw that in the report last week
any considerations under the new zealand
bill of rights act and the human rights
act
never saw any mention of that last week
and then it goes on to say
will you
sorry decide to require a vaccine pass
you must consider if workers in those
premises should be vaccinated last week
you were told you didn't have to
um
however you were given three options
i've already raised
a consideration of why
there wasn't an option to look at
having the venues
available
to people without passes
on alternate days
i'm vaccinated i can decide when i want
to go
other people in the community can't
excluding them in totality through red
orange and green
makes no sense
like
are we
or are we heartless
just me
thank you mr tribe it's open to
questions
rana
we have a copy of the presentation
yeah you can download it
thank you
thank you very much for your submission
this afternoon and for taking the time
to come along and join us we appreciate
jose
thank you
councillors that moves us on to um the
next item in our agenda which is the
minutes sorry actually we need to
remove the major label item yep so we've
got the major light item which is the
naming of the costello legacy
um
and the reason it came to hand after the
agenda was published reason why it can't
be delayed so we can progress in a
timely manner would somebody like to
move that the item be received
councillor scout councillor amundsen
for discussion
all in favor aye all right against
carrie thank you for that
we've got the
minutes from
november
9th of ppp
councillor sopa seconded
councillor skill
open for discussion
where's nana put the motion all in favor
against
carried
uh the minutes of the extraordinary
meeting on december 7th
somebody want to move those as a true
and correct record
i'll move
councillor rabbit and seconded miss cook
open for discussion
there is none i'll put the motion all in
favor
against
carried
it brings us to the amendment to the
community well-being fund committee
terms of reference mr morris
good afternoon everybody um
this is a relatively prosaic report all
we're doing is amending the governance
statement and delegations register in
light of some recent changes to the
terms of reference for the community
fund
with the addition of a youth councillor
it became
an opportune time to update those two
documents with that change to the terms
of reference but also to make a change
to ensure that we always meet quorum in
terms of the number of councillors who
are required so as if uh uh happy to
answer any questions
so just to clarify mr morris the first
three recommendations are things that
the committee can adopt the false as a
recommendation for council yes thank you
councillors the recommendations are on
your agenda um councillor lewis i'd like
to move those be accepted thank you it's
moved
councillor lewis seconded council sopher
it's up for discussion
committee chair councillor lewis have
you anything you want to add only that
the addition of an extra year it's
easier if you take the mask off it
certainly is that
my mind's working okay i think
um with the addition of the youth member
it's very important that we have the
better balance of the
councillors because the council of
quorum regulations and if it would be
we would have to have 100 exceptions
every time of of the councillors
involved
if um
and when the youth council member is
there because of the numbers obviously
the reference is easy
thank you mr morris can i ask if
we require another elected member to
attend what is the process we need to go
through to appoint that person
there's not so much appointing a person
it's nominating a person it's easier to
see you that way nominating a person and
substitution rather than appointing a
new person to that committee
if
council was to decide to appoint a
person to increase the quorum then that
would be a change through to the
governance statement and delegations
register
in addition to what we're doing today so
just the ability to nominate is quicker
and more efficient yes in this
circumstances thank you
in the easy way ma just asked mr morris
so if on thursday two or three of the
councils can't be there this case of the
quick ring rail yes thank you
thank you
council as it's been moved and seconded
i'll put the motion if there are no
further questions all in favor all right
against
carrie
thank you mr morris
thank you
uh the
proposed road name the right of way for
tane way
no they're not there michael
now they are
welcome along
we've got a recommendation for the
naming of tarnate way
i'll take the reporters read and if
there's any questions
counselors first of all we need a mover
i'll move
councillor evert councillor scalp open
for questions
well that was easy
we're coming down for i'll put the
motion all in favor
against
carried
nice to see that progress being made
that we talked about at the last minute
mr day this time you will need to take a
seat
no
uh the
procurement policy
ah
nick and hayden didn't recognize you
with your mask song
just make sure you grab that microphone
for us thank you
your worship counselors ladies and
gentlemen uh i'd take it so you've got
the report in front of you but if i may
i'd like to cover off on the salient
points that contain within
so this procurement policy was adopted
for engagement on the 29th of september
and was subsequent and the engagement
subsequently took place
forward to 22 october
we took a targeted approach
at suppliers in particular to council
and also to the broader ratepayers of
invercargill
so the engagement with the business
stakeholders centered around um our
webinar took place on the 12th of
october
and of interest there were 89 people
invited webinar 63 said they would
attend and 59 actually turned up online
so we're quite impressed with the number
who who logged in and were happy to
engage around this proposed policy
and the engagement with the wider public
was through our normal communication
channels and direct emails to those who
were interested
from that submission period there were
14 submissions received
of which half were from suppliers to
council and the other half were from
wider members of the public or special
interest groups
now the seven submissions from members
of the public were generally supportive
however
some requested changes be made most
slows were around socially interested
groups who wanted sort of stronger parts
of the policy put in
uh feedback from
the uh suppliers was relatively positive
and they just wanted some more clarity
around what some of the aspects of the
policy meant for them and when we
provided that they were pretty happy
uh that comes off i'm happy to take any
questions that the council may have
thanks hayden councillors we'll start
with the mover in a second that there
are four recommendations there
happened to second chair move councillor
seconded councillor lewis open for
questions
good numbers of people who had engaged
um which i guess was from what you were
saying perhaps higher than you'd
initially anticipated around the
question of
uh
social weightings
um how how did you resolve their off and
through through to the recommendations
in the presentation we did we spoke
about
the social
procurement representing somewhere
between naught and 10
of the non-price attributes
so to give an example if 30 percent's
price and seventy percent is uh
non-price attributes central procurement
could be anywhere from north to seven
percent that was a general guideline
there would be exceptions where that
could be higher particularly in areas
like artwork
possibly
thank you
council is any other further questions
or comments
it was easy i'll put the motion all in
favor
against
carried i guess one of the things that
helps is when you get really good
engagement it gives us confidence in the
decision-making process thank you for
your work through this thank you
next item is the southland softball
association sign proposal
welcome along caroline
good afternoon show your
worship um the
proposal you've got in front of you is
due to the fact our
reserves um omnibus management plan at
2014 is slightly out of date at this
point so it's
not enabling us to help this club put a
sign up that's in keeping with the area
within which it's cited
so this um
proposal is to enable that to happen
because it does require a council
resolution and then resource consent to
do so
so just a question of clarification from
my perspective caroline if it's uh
resource consent
non-notified limited or notified
um we are not sure at this point so i
have checked into that for your
counsellor and unfortunately until they
actually make the application with
insurance to whether it will be not
notified
okay thank you
councillors there are two
recommendations i'll move that way
councillor
and councillor amundsen
questions comments
put it to the vote all in favor
against
carrie thanks caroline
we got betty or trudy up for the next
item
trudy
welcome are you grabbing betty
just up at the top of the table there
betty welcome in from the departure
lounge
uh thanks for the preparation of the um
the annual dog report uh
is there anything that you wish to draw
our attention to
uh
just for the apologies for the lateness
of the report um
i can update that
as of the animal care facility and
exercise area will be completed by the
hopefully the 22nd of december
uh councillor's recommendation is that
the report is received i think it goes
we once it's received and adopted we put
it up on online correct yes thank you be
advertised move miss cook
seconded i've got a question
oh you gonna second it as well cancer
arnold
oh she can do it
counselor scout thank you councillor
another question right yeah i'm just
wondering um
you've got a um
in the table that i'm looking at here
yes you've got a lot of things kevin i'm
just wondering if it would be possible
to know if about the rehoming policy
there's a rehab policy and you and how
many dogs are euthanized i mean i know
those aren't pleasant things one's
pleasant one's not
but you've got you know barking dog
complaints you've got so many things
here yes but we don't have any idea
about that i mean if i did some sums
here it could be like a couple of
hundred
we always look to rehome and i can't
give you those correct figures i'm just
wondering it wouldn't be good to include
those in the table and the euthanased
how many of you tonight as well
trudy's going to have a crack
what the report is in our statutory
requirements that would be an addendum
but we're happy to look at that longer
term
good dude good to know to see how things
are trending and whatnot as part of the
whole whole process great nation thank
you councillor
no further questions or comments
councillor lewis thank you cheer just
very quick question but i presume it's
the covered situation that affected the
proactive
things between the 17 and whatever it
was for 489 which would go active
over time
yes you're through mr chair that's
correct the proactive patrols have been
reduced thanks
councillors i'll put the motion all in
favor
against
carrie thank you
uh rezoning of
seven and nine kennington road we'll
just wait for liz to come through
um this is a relatively technical plan
change so it's a change to the macabre
city district plan 2019
um the district plan
allows for
at the moment there's a piece of land on
kennington road that is owned industrial
but um the rural rules apply to that
because it's essentially a deferred zone
the landowner has done what is required
they now just need a council resolution
to get the industrial three zone rules
to apply to that piece of land so
um my only
change to the report that you have in
front of you would be recommendation
number two
that
the
committee recommends to council that it
resolves
um because it has to be a council
decision in the district plan
policy space
okay
happy to move both those recommendations
but the second one amended in that
straightforward way thank thank you
second day for that counselor
um can i just
check around the status of the interim
number liz
the
number has i've been there
resolution and in the recommendation
i've referred to 7n9 kennington road
however since the district plan was
drafted and after i've drafted this
report um a building consent came in so
we've now issued a number which is 15 a
kennington road which will encompass
both because there'll be buildings
across boundaries
so
the recommendation refers to seven and
nine because that's what's referred to
in the district plan provisions at the
recommendation includes their legal
descriptions just to clarify make sure
that we're clear that what land we're
talking about
thanks liz
councillors we've got
the recommendations moved and seconded
if there are no further questions
i'll put the motion
all in favor
against
carried canna morten would be handy
not for the report obviously
thank you
thank you
uh the activities report
welcome trudy
anything you'd like to draw um the
committee's attention to uh a slight
typographical error where we forgot the
percentage sign could you take the mask
off please trudy thanks there's a
typographical area with the percentage
sign missing off uh
the planning and building consent
processing times but other than that
uh it's still reasonably busy throughout
our customer and environment services
especially interesting to note the
higher number of limb requests
compared to this time last year the
property market is still quite wet
um and our teams have been continuing to
track well especially in the building
space in terms of those
site visits or inspections i should say
thank you
councillors
questions
i guess it's too too early treaty but um
probably the next report might
include some reflection on the the
vaccination passport status and the
impact that it's having on
various customer facing parts of our
business
certainly we can include that next time
thank you
councillors i'll move that the reports
received is there a secondary
cook thank you
questions or comments
i'll put the motion all in favor
against
carrie thanks trudy
grant don't go far thank you
uh so for this part of the agenda i'll
step back from the chair and let
councillor amundsen take over
um i have to declare a
potential conflict of interest is it a
conflict or an interest
um possibly both mr chair fine
then if you declare a conflict like me
you can step back
oh sure
thank you mr chair
uh so this item is the tip
residential development and it's a plan
change and so we have liz and grant and
happy to hear what you have to say about
it yeah good afternoon um
well really i don't think this
development needs any um great
introduction i'm sure we're all
aware of what it is and what it means
for the city
um
since this item was last brought to this
committee
we've had a
public submissions process and we've
held a hearing
the
hearings
panel has
recommended to this council to approve
the plan change essentially
as it was notified and as the council
had previously adopted
earlier in the year
so the recommendations in this report
are for the committee to receive this
report
and to recommend to the council
to approve it essentially
it's notified
awesome thank you very much
anybody have any questions about
this
plan change
or recommendations
too easy would somebody like to move the
two recommendations thanks councillor
sopa councillor kit
any further questions or discussion
all in favor say aye aye
against
carrich
could my vote be recorded as an
abstention yep
uh we're both recorded as declaring
conflict and withdrawing thank you
okay thanks grant thank you liz
councillors that brings us to the um
major late item
just
wait for the um
excuse me arrival of caroline
i'm not having an emotional moment i'm
just joking
so bearing in mind counselor rabbit you
um don't have the papers um
we've got our parks and rec manager
caroline who's going to go through the
the issue for us
thank you
caroline welcome again
so the major layout item really
appreciate you accepting this today what
we're looking at here is
actually agreeing on a name for the work
that we've been doing with the costello
family and the community in oshara on
the
pump track that we've created out there
for them
um
the background i think you all know is
around the 90 000 legacy that was left
by derek costello
um so we've used his money to install
this pump track and we would very much
like to
uh we would like
the committee to receive our
recommendation
around naming this
area
the gestalo park
councillors happy to move that way
and second of note i noted by the uh
deputy mayor of odata
councillor arnold
or other otara resident um
it's open for questions or comments
it's great to get it to this point it
really is
council lewis thank you very much it's
very appropriate it should be should
very appropriate they should have this
name and i'm sure the president's as
mentioned are very happy to do so and i
think it's a great call thank you
thank you
let's go
as somebody who was privileged to work
with derek
and knew he and his wife quite well i'm
delighted
thank you
it's really cool to get to this point
because it's been
a journey and i hate that phrase but it
really has been
thank you
councillors if there are no further
questions or comments it's been moved
and seconded i'll put that all in favor
against
carried thanks caroline thank you and
thank you councillors we have no items
in public excluded so uh i'll close them
just before closing the meeting because
this is no it's not our last baby on the
21st i'll close the meeting
thank you
you